I hope it ushers in a golden era for
Humanity I hope in the short term the
people who are going to do quality
assurance on the stuff that chat GPT
spits out they'll actually have an
outsized opportunity so like if you know
how to write code now you can write 10
times the code so the execution has been
delegated but you still have to validate
the code is correct or is good or does
the job that it needs to if I were to
ask you to write code I don't know how
to read code so it doesn't matter that
it can write code for me because I don't
know how to judge it so I still need a
human to do that and that human can now
check 10 times as much code or 100 times
as much code which means the value of an
expert increases in the short term long
term once the AI can check itself and
can do it better than a human can and
can check millions of lines of code